so we promise you at the top of the show
some very big news for our own jesse
waters he has been named the permanent
host of fox news's 7pm hour it will be
called jesse waters prime time it starts
two weeks from today on january 24th and
jesse one of the great joys in life is
when you can be genuinely so happy for
somebody else and i think that's how all
of us felt today learning of this great
news i do wonder will your viewers be
eligible for cash prizes at the end like
like on america's funniest home videos
because that was your real ratings
getter yes
there will be cash prizes
as of now
but i i think fox is going to look back
at this and say this is the best
programming decision
that they have ever made either the best
or the worst one or the other it's
either the best thing or the worst
decision they've ever made it's
destroyed this show it's destroyed the
five you are destroying the five because
what's going to happen is our ratings
are going to come out 4 30 p.m every day
and when i beat you you're going to be
sad
and then when you beat me i'm just not
going to speak through the entire show
so this is just a terrible decision
right so if you want gutfeld to speak
less watch the 7 o'clock hey jesse did
you think about putting an exclamation
point at the end of prime time i wanted
two exclamation points and legal is
working on that but someone at 11 is
putting up a hell of a fight total
exclamation point harold this is your
buddy here getting a new show
congrats man you know
skill matters uh performance matters and
talent matters and uh you've been
rewarded for it uh couldn't be prouder
for you i just hope you don't use the
perch to come after me uh in the seven
o'clock hour
no no i'm not going to lay a glove on
you harold you're safe and okay
just keep it just keep it here okay a
word to you katie
oh harold i would add to what you just
said and say jesse it's also about
paying your dues and you have done that
you've earned it we're so happy for you
and i have some advice about your hair
don't let them do it twice a day you
will damage it and we have to keep the
hair strong
i also look forward to the jessie and
greg wagers
throughout the week every single day
which i'm sure we will not get annoyed
about at all no
i'm not competing with gutfeld i'm up
against wheel of fortune
whoever's hosting jeopardy
they do about 8 million a night so jesse
real quick what did jesse jr say when he
heard the news
uh he wants an assistant
uh jesse jr and uh and i told johnny
that johnny now has to have an assistant
because you have to go through johnny's
assistant to get to johnny now to get to
me
well it's going to be great
two weeks from today write that down
harold and we will see that show when it
starts on the 24th hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else